ich halte es für ganz entscheidend dass
wir den Menschen auf dem Weg ins
Eigenheim helfen es ist nicht nur der
Wunsch aller jede Umfrage zeigt die
Menschen wollen in den eigenverbänden
wohnen es ist ja auch gesellschaftlichen
lebenswertes Team mehr Eigentum
Deutschland ist ja leider fast
Schlusslicht in Europa mehr Eigentum äh
schließt die die vermögenspreizung es
ist sichert die Person die es schafft
vor Altersarmut und übrigens auch die
Nachfolge Generation und wenn es uns
gelingt Viertel zu durchmischen nicht
nur sozial sondern Mietwohnung und
Eigentumswohnung dann sind die auch
stabiler aber derzeit ist es schwierig
das ist mir klar nur wenn es in der
akuten Krise da dürfen wir aber die
längeren Pläne nicht aus den Augen
verlieren und deswegen sage ich wenn es
jetzt schwierig ist dann müssen wir erst
recht angreifen dass Deutschland ein
eigentumsnation wird nicht nur als die
Menschen wollen sondern weil es auch gut
für die Gesellschaft ist Deutschland ist
ja in Europa weit abgeschlagen was die
eigenheimquote betrifft woran liegt es
denn haben wir nicht das Geld dafür
zögern wir woran liegt es oder lässt der
Staat uns vielleicht einfach
und zu wenig netto fürs Eigenheim es
sind tatsächlich viele Faktoren ja
meiner Meinung nach lässt uns der Staat
auch zu wenig vom Brutto mit Netto vom
Brutto war er tatsächlich auch mal eine
sehr prominierte Forderung die wir
wieder aufleben lassen müssten aber wir
haben mehrere Faktoren zum einen wir
haben sehr sehr starkes Mietrecht das
Bundesverfassungsgericht spricht bei
Mietrecht von Eigentums ähnlichen
Verhältnissen das zweite wir haben ein
Angebotslücke es ist zu wenig Wohnraum
da sowohl zu Miete als auch fürs
Eigentum das dritte ist die Preise
steigen enorm teilweise getrieben durch
Regulierung des Staates da können wir
sehr originär eingreifen und das vierte
ist auf dem Weg ins Eigentum ich habe zu
hohe Kaufnebenkosten und ich habe zu
viel Ansprüche an das eigene aber ich
habe so viel Notwendigkeit Eigenkapital
mitzubringen und wenn wir da an allen
diesen Stellen ansetzen das geht nicht
gleichzeitig es geht nicht gleichzeitig
dieses Wort überall aber wir müssen
anfangsschriften die sind in Deutschland
ja auch wirklich fast schon die Zar kann
man sagen wo auch viele gar keine Lust
haben sich damit auseinanderzusetzen wie
ist denn da ihre Erfahrungen mit ja also
erstens da sind wir einer Meinung
zweitens zum Thema Bauvorschriften ich
habe ein besonders kurioses Beispiel das
ist schön ich hätte auch eins bieten
können ja wir geben in Deutschland
inzwischen 10 Milliarden Euro jährlich
für Brandschutz aus haben aber seit 30
Jahren keine sinkenden Todeszahlen von
Brandopfern also sollte die mit einer
Zigarette im Bett einschlafen die die
Trift ist leider manchmal und Sterben
das ist aber da können sie so viel
Brandschutztüren einbauen wie Sie wollen
die sterben ja an dem Dampf in den in
dem Zimmer jedenfalls sie sehen
überhaupt gar kein also während wir bei
den wir warten immer bei 20.000
Verkehrstoten im Jahr bei weniger
Verkehrs haben wir mehr Verkehr und
leider immer noch 3.000 aber das ja
schon mal signigant weniger dann Geld
investiert da haben wir noch Ergebnis
beim Brandschutz Null jetzt finden Sie
mal den Politiker der sagt und da muss
ich mal die Medien sehen wir machen
jetzt mal eine brandschutzvorschrift Weg
die muss gar nicht mehr sein meistens
haben sie ganz industrie-lobby gegen
sich aber sie finden auch immer
irgendeinen Professor der sagt es ist
totaler Wahnsinn also wie kann man denn
die Gefährten die armen Schüler die dann
in der Schule sitzen oder in der Brand
so also deswegen wird er sich keiner
trauen Politiker vielleicht Geld
bekommen für jede Vorschrift die sie
abschaffen und für jedes gibt ja
wirklich viele in diesem Land
vielleicht wäre das ein Anreiz wieso
bonus-systems der auf Stahl oben drauf
sein müssen wir erhöht ich weiß kein
Mensch das würde aber enorm Steigerung
Kostensteigerungen immer das wird
natürlich auch dazu weniger
trittschalldämmerung ist auch ein
Problem
aber mit Trittschall ist besonders ach
so die Leute geben mehr Geld dafür aus
dass sie eine Altbauwohnung sind wo sie
ihren Nachbarn viel stärker erholen in
der Neubauwohnung haben sie fast die
Verhältnisse von dem Fernsehstudio
Problem
ja die Thema energetische Gebäude
Gebäudesanierung was natürlich wichtig
ist dass man da auch die Gebäude vor
Klimaschutz nach vorne bringen aber das
ist natürlich ein riesen Problem man mit
Immobilienexperten spricht die der
wirklich tief drin sind dass das so ein
Unsicherheitsfaktor ist dass da einfach
viele sich ja wahrscheinlich gar nicht
mehr trauen werden also die die Sachen
jetzt auch loswerden wollen weil das
einfach so ein Risiko ist unberechenbar
es gibt natürlich von der Politik schon
gewisse Pläne aber das ist alles noch
ein bisschen undurchschaubar da kann ich
natürlich erst Investor dann auch schwer
kalkulieren also da kommen sicherlich
auch noch ja einige Probleme das ist
alles noch so ein bisschen in der
Schwebe ähm dann haben das
inflationsproblem Fertigstellung Risiken
das auf einmal Keller wenn Sie heute
noch das eigene Tun das Eigenheims
Investitionen empfehlen gerade nicht
also gerade das immer schwer jetzt eine
kurzfristige Prognose zu treffen aber
wir hatten jetzt natürlich eine extreme
vermögenspreis Inflation in den letzten
Jahren auch getrieben durch die
niedrigen Zinsen das hat sich jetzt das
kommt euch jetzt natürlich nicht so
dagegen mit dem Vorhaben jetzt gerade
die Zinsentwicklung mal schauen wie
nachhaltig ist wie weit es noch geht
aber momentan kippt das ganze bzw es ist
schon gekippt und wenn man mit Leuten
spricht die da wirklich ganz tief drin
sind
Kredite nicht mehr bedienen zu können
genau klar also es ist natürlich immer
schwer jetzt deutscher Markt
amerikanischer Markt das ist immer
schwer das kann man sich alles in einen
Topf werfen aber da ist schon einiges
jetzt gerade ist schon gekippt ist noch
am kippen Immobilienmarkt ist natürlich
sehr träge das ist jetzt nicht wieder
Aktienmarkt dass das innerhalb von ein
paar Tagen geht sondern da muss
natürlich erstmal einiges in Gang kommen
aber man hört da schon sehr viele Sachen
dass er gewisse Projekte sehr schwer
verkauft werden und dass man jetzt dann
aber das ist natürlich auch teilweise es
hat auch Vorteile dass man vielleicht in
einen Käufermarkt genau kommen könnte
wieder und das ist das tatsächlich eine
sehr interessante Entwicklung die wir
beobachten müssen wir haben
alle ihre Argumente hören aber einmal
einmal so auch noch reinholen weil
ansonsten kommt ihr heute auch wirklich
zu kurz wie sieht es denn aus heutzutage
mit dem Bauen man sagt ja immer
polemisch vielleicht auch früher konnte
der Handwerker bauen heutzutage kannst
nur noch der Millionär wie ist es da
ich glaube dass wir vor allem hier in
Berlin aber im großen Städten ein großer
Problem haben dass wir zu wenig
Wohnungen haben dass Menschen wirklich
monatelang warten oder suchen und
manchmal klappt es gar nicht also ich
kenne vor allem ganz viele Flüchtlinge
die wirklich seit Jahren nach eine
Wohnung suchen und das nicht finden in
Berlin das ist ein riesen Problem und
ich glaube dass wir wie sie sagen in
eine Situation kommen wo Leute die schon
ihre eigenen haben gekauft haben das
nicht mehr leisten können also die
Kredite nicht mehr Leistung und das
trifft mich das trifft auch ganz ganz
viele Leute das ist eine Situation wo
ich wünsche dass halt die Regierung auch
irgendwie Pläne hat um das zu schützen
aber ich sehe wenn weil weltweit
anschauen ich sehe dass die
Wohnungsmarkt dass sie Immobilienmarkt
katastrophaler Entwicklungen vorhat in
der letzten Jahr da muss natürlich
einfach sagen ich muss mir jetzt auch
gegensteuern also
können wir rein wir haben zehn Jahre
lang drüber diskutiert dass die sehr
niedrigen Zinsen die Investoren auf den
Markt locken weil man da relativ
sicheres Beton Gold ist da immer das
Begriff Anlage hat die Investoren wir
jetzt durch die Steigung Zinsen
abgeschreckt das heißt es tatsächlich
sehen wir auch Preis Abschwünge
zumindest ja teilweise hängt davon ab
wenn sie hinschauen also es wird es wird
Indizien dass es günstiger werden könnte
sind da wir sind noch nicht überall der
Fall aber damit wäre schon mal was
geworden aber
günstiger also ich bin ja ich bin ja
nicht hier weil ich mit dem Status kurz
zufrieden bin wieder die Politik
gegangen weil ich unzufrieden bin mit
dem Status Quo dann müssen wir
Gegenleistung dafür noch verantwortlich
sein dass Menschen bauen also die
Anspruchshaltung die ihr schon da ist
der Staat würde schon richten ob bei
Finanzkrise corona-pandemie
machen
eingezogen dass es schwieriger geworden
ist und da kann man mit Fug und Recht
verlangen dass die zurückgenommen werden
bestes Beispiel sind Nebenkosten
während dieses Jahr noch auf den Weg
bringen die Liberalisierung der
Grunderwerbsteuer gegenfinanziert durch
es wird ein bisschen technisch sehr
Deals also durch das was unternehmen
Immobilienmarkt machen finanziert
teilweise gegen was Häuslebauer bekommen
um in Freibetrag bei der
Grunderwerbsteuer zu bekommen das ist
eine Hürde die wir die wir tatsächlich
wegnehmen wollen weil er Heilmann zu
Recht in Brandschutz an gesprochen hat
also wenn ich thematisieren Bundestag
freue ich mich auf ihren Applaus weil
wir ist ja nicht nur dass wir unseren
Brandschutz verschärfen die europäische
Nachbarn Österreich Schweiz Polen
Tschechien zeigen uns wie es deutlich
günstiger geht ohne dass die höhere
Todeszahlen hätten also ich muss gar
nicht in die Vergangenheit schauen das
ist übrigens auch noch ein Thema wo man
vielleicht doch mal genauer hinschauen
sollte ob alles so sinnvoll ist ja beim
Bauen übrigens der Schallschutz auch wir
haben tatsächlich die dicksten
Betondecken in Europa völlig absurd weil
wir eine Vorstellung haben dass man in
so einer schallkabine leben muss das
kann alles reduziert werden nur und da
bin ich bei meiner Heimann da braucht
man eine politische Mehrheit wir werden
stricken wir werden es auch formulieren
aber noch ist sie nicht da beim
Naturschutz bin dabei Ihnen das ist eine
harte den Grünen aber in einem
versiegelten Raum also wenn ich in einem
in der Stadt Gebäude ergänze aufbaue
ausbaue wenn ich es auch vielleicht
Abreise und Neubau warum brauche ich
dann achten dass ein versiegelter Raum